la facilité
sont les jours qui m'ont manqué
donne moi le goût
donne moi le jus du vin
ce sont les jours qui apportent
ton sens
je sens le calme du soleil
et je me sens bien
parfois quand les lumières se ferment
tôt
je  souviens-toi de toi quand je commence à sourire
même si maintenant tu ne veux pas me connaître
je m'entends et je fais
un effort supplémentaire
ce sont les temps de l'amour et des yeux sens
ce sont les jours de rêve sans fin
les ennuis de la vie sont jetés  loin
comme un feu brûlant
ce sont les jours
pour que nous traversions quand nous avons traversé
peut-être que cela n'a pas fonctionné
mais nous avons fait de notre mieux
ce sont les
jours qui disent
donne-moi la chasse à donner  moi la joie de l'
été blanc
ce sont les jours qui m'apportent
je sens le calme d'une chanson est
ce que
je sens les sceaux
du soleil
et je
me sens
bien